To rectify this situation, Microsoft made a standards
proposal that reconciles touch events and mouse events and
pen input too, into one model called pointer
events. So you'll notice that pointer events are currently
only natively implemented on Internet Explorer and IE
mobile. For all the other browsers out there, you're
going to need a poly fill library built on
top of touch events. Luckily, there's a great poly
fill library out there as part of the polymer project.
This is what I used to implement pointer event handling
in my synthesizer. The set of pointer events should look
pretty familiar to you if you used mouse events before. They
basically map all the mouse events directly. And then add
the pointer cancel event from touch, as well. The pointer
event, itself, derives from mouse event. So it gets all
the same coordinates as mouse events. As well as a few
things from touch. It has a unique pointer
ID, similar to that touch ID we saw in
touch events. And, it also has a width and
a height of the touch point in touch cases.
For pen cases it may have pressure or tilt.
And, of course, the pionter event tells you what
type of pointer it is, whether it's a mouse
pointer or a touch pointer or a pen input.